so ryan gosling and Russell Crowe are
straight up the coolest [ __ ] guys in
Hollywood I don't know I just walked out
of this movie that's the information I
got the nice guys so the nice guy stars
Ryan Gosling and Russell Crowe and is
directed by Shane Black and then the
nice guys Ryan Gosling plays a private
investigator looking for someone Russell
Crowe I would call him a private
investigator but he's pretty much an
enforcer for hire like if someone's
giving you trouble someone you don't
like is out there someone owes you money
you hire Russell Crowe Russell Crowe
will find the guy who be like hey are
you selling so dad you'll deck him break
his arm do whatever we like hey pay your
dues he'll lock off super chill guy - I
love how Russell Crowe is just chill and
professional about all of it the exact
opposite of Ryan Gosling is pretty
high-strung and unprofessional so the
two are working their cases they find
out their cases cross paths sort of like
hey let's team up and work together on
this so now you have the weirdest buddy
not cop duo ever it's really enjoyable
one two cuz these two work I mean
there's one thing that carries this
entire movie it's these guys I mean
granted the premise is great in this
setting is great this is Los Angeles in
1977 and they're investigating
ultimately the porn industry is involved
in porn in the 70s sweaty people bad
lighting cheesy dialogue you really
don't know where Los Angeles in the 70s
ends and porn begins or klux Angeles now
for that matter the city was cool I mean
the culture of the 70s especially in a
place like Los Angeles is just it's an
interesting place that's another thing
about this movie you're interested in
the investigation you actually get
intrigued you're like I want to know all
right
hmm let's put that right let's put this
together you need the board and you'd
like to tack pictures and draw strings
and lines to places and people not just
because of the porn aspect you animals
and it is actually interesting what's
happening and although I can speak about
how Russell Crowe and Ryan Gosling have
great chemistry and carry this movie
there's just stand out in this movies
Ryan Gosling's daughter this girl was
actually really cool the movie she was
useful she was relevant she actually did
[ __ ] a lot of times you have a 13 year
old girl paddling around with these two
investigators you're like all right
you're gonna be dead weight it's gonna
be an escort mission you don't want to
do she was kind of like Ellie from The
Last of Us she like oh you're like an
adult mind in a young person's body and
you're actually getting stuff done
that's actually good on you good on you
and I like the humor in this movie too
anytime you can incorporate humor
a movie about crime is it's just more
fun I had chuckles along the way and I
loved the banter and the dialogue in
this movie but nothing had me just
laughing out loud stomach hurting the
thing I would have liked to have seen
but it's not completely necessary
because the movies not pitched that way
and there's this professional this
hitman in his movies pretty much like
the Iceman of killers this guy is cool
as hell
and I wanted to see more of him he
doesn't show up until much later in the
movie and he only shows up briefly and
granted I get it because you don't want
to saturate the entire movie with that
dude you want to leave the audience want
anymore he's cool because you don't see
him a lot it's kind of like going for
that Boba Fett thing they can't help
blocking life in this movie god I wanted
to see more of that did it dude was
awesome guys in the end the nice guys
was actually a refreshing take for the
genre a genre of crime investigative
clever comedies he needed something
refreshing to hit it I think this is the
movie I don't really get time with this
movie there are things in the movie I
would have wanted to see more of but
that's my personal preference it's a
movie that I say right now is a great
time no alcohol required however
admittedly after doing this for a few
years I've seen some [ __ ] I know when I
see a movie that would be better the
second time I watch it or when I reflect
on it a lot of tangled webs get woven in
this movie there are layers to peel back
that actually makes for great movie -
it's a good sign right there right guys
so the nice guys have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's your
favorite crime comedy out there you can
say pulp fiction if you want it's
cheating but you can say but whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more